ein aufschlagen kann
leute wie beschreiben sie das denn aus
josefsson herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge der hacker show wie immer
zeigt heute die fünf besten hacker
einsendung der letzten woche wie immer
wenn ihr auch mal dabei sein wollt ladet
euer material als ungelöstes video auf
youtube hoch und schickt man den link
per youtube das war schon ganz erklären
auch wenn ich würde sagen wir starten
jetzt mit der ersten sendung die stadt
von cali spielt heißt für sk sternchen
das volle programm sternchen lkw ok
lüttich ein bisschen komisch die wand
hoch habe ich gefühl wahrscheinlich
jetzt das coupé warum softtop achten wie
es bewegt wenn jemand so umlauf mit dir
unten anschauen damit schlägt dann wisst
ihr schon der bislang mega schöne aus
über diesen sport zu geleiten
natürlich jetzt den gleiter aktiviert
ihr klassiker wie immer bevor die
kleider loslegen seht ihr jetzt bekommen
wir so kleine schaden
was wird als nächstes machen schlägt die
luft die füße schnell die wand okay dass
ein gegner der sich die kinder zeigen ja
natürlich
es galt aber ganz mut weiter intakt gar
kein schaden kam als ich das richtig
moment warten
ok vorsitz auf
da war jetzt nicht dieser tipp den er
bei den möglichen schaden bekommen hat
ich weiß gar nicht ich dachte ich müsste
man immer einkaufen im glos kleinen zu
können wie ist es denn muss man zwingend
diesen schaden stick bekommen um
loslegen zu können
oder geht es auch ohne weil es jetzt
auch ohne abgehoben hat den aber der
vorschlag bekommen wo leute aber davor
da kommen zweifel unten erfolg was war
das gerade da unten kommen sie jetzt
hoch und hätten sie ihn irgendwie es
springt einfach los und fliegt einfach
weg okay dann wenn man diesen riesenberg
der hoch klettert er würde ja denn jesus
hält natürlich auch diesen typ mann
angreifen werden fliegt einfach weg
werde ich mich ab damit zu platzen
nummer vier
sein sohn stammt von bob bbb oder das
video ganz klassisch es kate ob hacker
genannte young bob young bob inkl
bobbi g ok ja da haben wir so ein spiel
das ich vielleicht auffällig verhält in
der lobby kommen so da ist was warte
warum fliegen da oben menschen durch die
gegend das ist nicht mehr die ja das ist
noch ein anderer
also war vor zwei hacker in der runde
sind
ich wusste gleich dass überhaupt jemand
rage gespielt aber zwei heck alles klar
was macht er jetzt reden alle stars
schill die da oben wahrscheinlich nicht
gebaut leute macht nicht so eine scheiße
ist schilder zu zweit oben in der luft
und schießen wir feiern wo hinein kann
man nicht mal sehen
herr willis hat gesehen wie viele leute
fliegen einfach dieser runde
und was für bescheuerte spitex hamid
also mindestens zwei ich habe fast kein
gebildet während dritter gewesen
ja warum hacken so viele thema 716 blut
raffl darauf den kopf warum hacken so
viele in rage mode ich mein essen drei
sind wirklich
alter was kam horn dreifachen frei
hacker rage modus nur ernst jetzt um die
ecke dann sieht man einfach eins zwei
drei leute in der luft herum fliegen
bundes halt wirklich frei es ist ein
verkauf komme
lasst uns zurück springt zunächst eine
einzige nummer drei die stammt von
mustafa g-punkt leute talking about
sinnlose übertriebene hacks was ist das
für ein speed weil der junge portet sich
erfasst das kratzt das hört die nicht
der typ hatten roth pilsken daran im
hintergrund einfach in sein rotes
kommentare oder far cry das ist timo ja
glaub ich klar ich würde schon sagen es
unsichtbar geworden
aber nein er hat sie einfach es sieht
aus als würde sich porten der so ein
gestörtes bietet aus als würde sich
pforten und hat sich dann einfach den
look like sonic in eckige reportet
nennen wir es mal locker auch aber der
locker klar bei der range bitte komm
nicht machen
er hat imo ist hat schon bei so was
schon ein bisschen bisschen scheiße
hatte jetzt vitalclub der hand
das ist so was geht so übertrieben das
bieten wir auch eine kleine range von
was war das jetzt gerade 78 blöcken da
kommst ja gar nicht ran
die gar nicht irgendwie also dass er
kommt ein apfel kann nicht rankommen mit
nahkampf kann er diesen typen nicht
angreifen keinen schaden machen jetzt
jetzt kommt daran weil da nur über die
kinder ausgestellt und getötet hat jetzt
macht also wieder an der kommt durch das
ein ausgemachter wieder an
da kommt man nicht daran so eiskalt so
das war's soweit um platz drei es wird
jetzt spannend wir gehen unter die top 2
und springt zu platzen nummer ruby
diese 1 sendung stammt von reiner
wahnsinn
und es sieht so aus als wäre es gestellt
also die gesamte server aus keine
rüstung billig gebaut das hause sein
freund auf server aber guckt euch das
man normalerweise schafft es überhaupt
keine einsendung reihen die eingestellt
sind weil ich eine gestellten
einsendungen ich will niemand nicht dass
irgend jemand mit seinem freund aufnimmt
und soll willkommen in die hacker
schaffen ich will einfach die
diskussionen den kommentaren sehen
darüber wie das hier geht also wie
gesagt so klassisches haus das sind 130
kilo weil pop ziemlich schnell sprintet
steht schon mal vier weg und jetzt eins
aufschlagen kann
leute wie bescheiden sieht das denn aus
alte ihr als liegt ein noch flacher ich
liebte was amtlich das an wie bescheuert
sie das aus er hat ihn gequält aber
obwohl der tus kann der andere noch
schlagen jetzt ist er noch tote pass auf
alles klar was zur hölle ist dass man
die keyword immer noch und gleicht
einfach so es steckt in der wand ist
eigentlich tot ich muss mich korrigieren
leute erst einmal gestorben hier schlägt
den immer noch weiter so also erst jetzt
so gestorben sogar so leichte schräglage
schild so bis in der waadt mit dem kopf
dann zweimal gestorben mit sieht er noch
flacher also gestorben
wenn man das jetzt steigern könnte wenn
es davon komparativ gebe das sieht
einfach so dämlich aus weil klasse weil
ich finde dass der typ auch schon sehr
schnell dahin läuft also könnte fast
auch ein spitex seiler potter nicht
gesteckt mehrere jetzt mit dem fire
aspect ihr schwert weg und dann das
was zulässt dass leute also mich würd's
brennend interessieren was das ist es
ist ein bug ist es ein hack und wie
macht man das über die fallen alle
experten getroffen schreibt das
unbedingt in den kommentare damit wir
darüber diskutieren können und
informiert werden es gibt auch bis zum
die informationen über das tor ein
format das wasser von platz nummer zwei
dieser woche und jetzt kommt's platz
nummer eins haltet euch fest ich habe
mich an
drei tage später alles klar ich würde
einfach gerade meine aussage untermalen
dem ich mich wirklich an einem mikrofon
am festhalte
was mache ich reiße das mikrofonkabel
raus die aufnahmen bricht ab super danke
schön
ok trotzdem will das nicht aufhalten wir
springen jetzt in sind weiter zu platz
nummer eins haltet euch einfach an
irgendwas fest was nicht rausreißen kann
dann ist alles gut
zb fakih handy schon wieder wirklich
haltet euch einfach nicht fest wenn ihr
nicht festhalten aber wir legen jetzt
loskommen die einsendung gestammt von
elias knapp doch wir gucken mal rein
okay er kriegt ja wirklich aus dem
nichts hits es ist wenige server hätte
der geschrieben von emmi schreibt von wo
das harmlose dagegen gehalten
ihr kriegt einfach aus dem nichts sitzt
und für die ganze darunter drei ihren
schabernack mit ihm jetzt immer wenn er
hier schicke pass auf jetzt schon wieder
wetten vor der geist der typ sieht die
typen einfach eiskalt nicht wenn sie
ansteht sind die sofort weg wie wir das
sofort springt man anfangs hätte hier
guckt jetzt aber auch nichts dessen man
sieht niemanden er wird aus dem nichts
geschlagen dass der junge sich gedacht
haben muss alter da sagt zack zack zack
er kriegt man jetzt und niemand ist da
ist durchaus frustrierend würde ich
sagen du kannst du die fans spielen wir
ganz regulär auf einmal wird musste mich
zu schlagen man sieht die gegner nicht
anschlägt und es passiert 34 mal wieder
sagt also so oder so wieder das okay
leute mit diesem geiste heck endet auch
die hacker für diese woche schön dass
ihr der beirat wenn euch gefallen der
kann gern michaels kommentare lassen die
nächste folge hacker schon geht es
nächste woche sonntag wie immer jede
woche jeden sonntag gibt eine neue folge
hacker show ansonsten möchte ich morgen
wieder mit dem nächsten video formiert
bis dahin hat rein machen